so women tend to cry easier than men
right so if you're in an argument and
you have that urge to cry
and i just stuff it down i think i just
hide it somewhere
in me and it's just stored so in the
last couple of years i've gotten better
at if i'm really upset about something
i'll go have a cry
and then i'll feel better and then i
don't have to carry around this horrible
negative energy that just poisons
everybody around me
i don't think hiding your pain somewhere
and makes it go away
i'm screaming a pillow a lot yeah
i feel better but doing that in front of
another person
i don't think it's and they're gonna be
like you're a little crazy right now so
working out is really helpful i'm boxing
twice a week and it's like okay i can
get it out i can punch it out i'm
running i'm doing stuff that makes me
tired where i can process it through my
mind my heart and then just release it
through sweat
having therapy to talk about these
things so you don't hold on to them is
really
helpful and also talking to the person
that you're frustrated with in a healthy
way